PROFESSOR: So in Mesoamerican
cosmology and its creation stories,
which-- there are many types.
There is one theme that really helps
us understand divination and prediction
practices among the
Aztecs and then the Maya.
And the story goes
that, in the beginning,
as in many paradisiacal stories--
in the beginning, there
was a period of time
where heaven and earth were close
together, where the beings who existed
could speak to animals, where
divinities and humans were almost
on the same plane.
Our ancestors and divinities
were close, and they all
had the same powers of
seeing, of observing.
But in the Mesoamerican case,
what happens is, the deities--
for some reason, they become
jealous that the ancestors,
who are closer to humans,
who've not yet been created,
have the same powers that they have.
And then they decide that
they don't like this.
And so they create a separation.
And the way they create the separation
is, they cast a spell over the vision--
over the eyes of the
ancestors, which is described
as though a breath on a mirror.
And there's still a mirror, but when
the ancestors-- and, eventually,
the humans-- look into the
mirror, they can't see as clearly.
They can't see as far into the mirror.
They can't see themselves.
They can't see the world.
And, therefore, what happens is
that, when human beings are created,
they inherit this breath over
the mirror, over their eyes.
And they can still see the
world that all of us see.
But, in fact, the world is
so much more full of life.
It's all around-- that we can't see.
And, therefore, the divinities can see.
They can see inside of trees.
They can see inside of our bodies.
They can see through mountains.
They can see great distances--
all things that we cannot do.
And so what happens is that
certain individuals in the society
are born who have a little
bit more capacity for vision,
and those often become the diviners.
They have to undergo
training, special training,
to take this extra ability
to see that moves them
a little closer to the
ancestors or to the divinities.
And they take this training-- what
we might call shamanistic training--
to sharpen this ability.
And they're often the ones who can read
the signs, who become the diviners.
But this idea of the mirror is very
important in Mexico and Mesoamerica
because many of these
mirrors were made out
of obsidian, this black obsidian stone
that was very brittle and very sharp,
but it could be shined.
You could shine it.
And when you looked into it--
and I've looked into them--
you can see yourself.
Now, you can't see themself as clearly
as when we look into our mirrors,
but you can see yourself.
And sometimes, you can
see things behind you.
And so these mirrors become very
important for humans as techniques
to improve their own ability to see.
By having these mirrors, it improves,
clarifies that breath on the eyes.